animal foundation still putting limits
on dog intakes they're only taking in
aggressive sick confiscated or dangerous
dogs but it has been more than three
weeks now since a deadly respiratory
virus spread through the shelter on
Mojave Road near Bonanza and that's also
meaning it's paused all of its intakes
its adoptions and transfers but as
Victoria Saha reports that just added to
previous issues she's got an update now
on how they're trying to move forward
yeah these are images shared To Us by
Las Vegas city councilwoman Victoria
Seaman and an unannounced visit there
she was concerned about the conditions
she says she hopes it can get better if
the city takes more of an authority
a respiratory illness amongst some of
their dogs forced the facility to close
earlier this month the animal foundation
should have had emergency protocols in
place after covet the animal foundation
is home to the dogs of Clark County
North Las Vegas and the city of Las
Vegas all three jurisdictions provide
millions of taxpayer dollars to the
foundation to keep up with the intake
but when eight staff members quit in
September citing poor management Fosters
were needed for dogs then days later
word got out about a sick Foster dog on
October 3rd there was a social media
post about halting operations because 16
dogs were symptomatic of canine
pneumovirus then the next day they said
they actually found out about the sick
dog days prior on September 28th that
dog had to be euthanized on the 10th 40
dogs were sick as of October 20th 73
dogs were showing symptoms and as of
this afternoon the foundation tells me
and the finish line is near and soon
councilwoman Victoria Seaman says she
doesn't want to see the situation get
worse she was the one who motioned an
audit be done in the last city council
meeting her team agreed I need help from
my Council to finally say enough is
enough during that meeting some of the
recommendations were having a council
member sit on the board but in text
messages exchanged between CEO Hillary
gray and Brian Knutson she asked why are
we different from any vendor but the
council wants continuous updates
I have made numerous requests to the
animal foundation to allow our cameras
inside to see the changes they say they
have made and to talk to gray my
requests as you can see have been denied
every time Victoria Saha eight news now
and Victoria a quick update here to your
story just into our Newsroom here in the
last few minutes a brand new update to
those dogs who are sick the animal
foundation telling us now more than 115
dogs are clear of the virus and of those
a hundred are available to adoption and
about a dozen or so dogs still have
symptoms this is a fluid story so be
sure to check the website before heading
over